hi I'm an oppressor Robinson for
gamespot and i'm here in the EA booth at
e3 2014 which is all abuzz with all
sorts of crazy lights and sounds and I'm
lucky enough to be standing here with
David rudder or David rata as I may be
properly pronounced right yeah just saw
and he is the executive producer for
FIFA 15 so what can we expect from this
awesome new FIFA game oh well the idea
really this year was to try and inject
as much emotion and passion and feeling
into the game so I feel the game this
year and we've done that in there a
number of different ways firstly with
incredible visuals that really capture
the kind of atmosphere and the look of
the players the pitch you know we're now
tracking all of the footprints on the
pitch and then just stunning really
stunning new lighting and everything
like that as well as also with unrivaled
intelligence as far as the team tactics
to really inject a kind of emotional
sense of you know winning and losing so
there's you know the a change the way
the teams are playing based on that and
also the players now have memory so
they're tracking the context of the
match and interactions with other
players and also the control of the
players too so you can really feel the
way that they should be moving
accelerate and cut our turns are with a
lot more punch than you could before and
the games just got a lot more
personality and a lot more
responsiveness I'm really fascinated by
this emotional side of games that we've
been hearing a lot about from EA how do
you go about programming emotions and
memory into a player in a game so it's
great question i mean for us really it's
something we've always wanted to be able
to do but we just haven't had power on
the last generations of console so this
year what we really wanted to do was if
you imagine in a real sport generally
the interactions between the players on
the pitch i actually have some sort of
history and an outcomes based on your
few key tackling me I'm kind of kind of
get a bit annoyed with you after a
period of time so this idea that the the
story of a match wasn't just about the
the scoreline the story of the match was
also about how the players felt about
each other including on their own teams
too so if a goalkeeper makes you know
repeated mistakes his defenders are
going to feel bad towards him the same
as you know if a strike he keeps missing
scoring opportunities he's going to kind
of feel disappointed himself but the
teammates around them
gonna be on chastising Yemen and telling
him what they think as well so it's the
next generation of consoles that's
allowed you guys to do this technically
absolutely yeah very cool and also on
this next generation we're seeing
stunning graphics and you're mentioning
about how you're going to be leaving
marks on the pitch and you have the
audience around you what are we going to
see visually that's so exciting in this
game so really it's from from the ground
up literally so as far as the test
concerned now every time I play at Red's
on the grass we're tracking it for the
entire duration of the pitch so the
longer the match goes on the more
distress there is it players make slide
tackles they'll actually leave streaks
on the pitch they'll get mud on them as
well if it's a wet day or it's a
particularly hard slide tackle that's a
kind of visual thing more than anything
but it really adds to the kind of
grounding of the players on the pitch as
well beyond that I mean we looked at the
rake the actual bones of the player
underneath their model and overhaul that
so they're a lot more believable and
then actually the players themselves the
model what we found last year was that
they kind of felt a bit too chunky so
we've actually leaned them out made them
more athletic and that really makes them
look a lot more realistic on the pitch
to and we've added new lighting physical
based lighting this year which means
we're using the environment and the
physical characteristics of all the
materials to actually give really
authentic lighting and it actually makes
the game look way more realistic than
previous years and then obviously you
know gone to town on the physical
likenesses of the place team and we're
going to be seeing real actual you know
football pitches and real players and
things like that you know actual places
that we would visit in real life right
absolutely so for us you know this this
emotional theme going rent for you out
the inciting what we throughout the
entire game what we wanted to do was
represent the individual teams as well
so for many of the stadia and many of
the teams now what we're trying to do is
capture the culture of the country or
the team or the leak that they're in so
you know the Bombonera which is a really
famous kind of cauldron of sport really
give it that kind of sense of emotion
and passion the cop as well at Anfield
and the post known as well that the s we
have now all of those things that really
represent the emotion the intensity and
the culture of those teams so what kind
of player do you think this game is
going to really really appeal to online
anyone who likes sports anyone who likes
a competitive video game anyone that
likes football soccer
obviously and just generally anyone who
likes to sit on a couch play a
one-on-one game against one of their
buddies and really tear it up and have
fun sounds great thank you so much for
your time David I really appreciate it
no worries anytime let me know if you're
excited for people any other EA games by
tweeting at an oppressor with the
hashtag gamespot III